[Music]  drew barrymore an ex-husband will  Kopelman splint nearly a year ago but  the actress tells Andy Cohen she's still  not seeing anyone and won't be for a  while I'm not ready I'm not I'm just  yeah I'm still in shock you are yeah I'm  gonna take Wow drew says it's a whole  new world out there since the last time  she was single I've never been on a  dating app and I now know that's the  current thing and my girlfriends are on  it so it is fun for me to like look over  their shoulder while they're going  through it I by the way Briah is every  if you want to date an actor or musician  there the actress is proudly flaunting a  new figure she recently revealed she  lost 20 pounds for her role in the  Netflix series santa clarita diet  everyone is asking me how is it that I  feel younger more energetic and sexier  than I have in years  it's the santa clarita diet